there's an air of excitement in El
Salvador over Sunday's national election
and it's all because of this man
Salvadoran president naib
buele he's the self-described world's
coolest dictator who in five short years
has managed to transform El Salvador
from one of the most dangerous places in
the world into arguably the safest
country in Latin America today
Salvadorans like Gabi casades can walk
around freely in downtown s Salvador
without having to worry about being
robbed or falling victim to gang
violence I think the majority of
everybody would agree it's the security
uh to be honest it's not something that
I would come to the center of downtown
El salador I think that's one of the
things that we're really happy about
with ch security of course you know it
has taken some hard measurement to do it
those hard measures Gabby refers to
include the so-called state of exception
and
which has been used to justify an
indefinite suspension of constitutional
rights and carry out a nationwide
Crackdown on
gangs it's a model that even other Latin
American leaders from countries where
insecurity is a problem have sought to
emulate a model that critics say
represents a threat to Salvadoran
[Music]
democracy the so-called Bui model is
nothing more than Breaking with the
democratic system breaking with
institutions breaking with fundamental
rights breaking with the International
Community with the basic principles of
coexistence among countries in other
words it is a dictatorship like the ones
we have had here in Latin America and
currently have will be it
disguised the argument from Human Rights
and civil liberties experts is that bu's
popularity is largely driven by a
willingness from Salvadorans to
sacrifice the country's democratic
values in the long term for for the sake
of living in peace now Salvadoran voters
may have concerns over the future of
their country's democracy and the loss
of certain civil liberties but support
for president naiv bu and his reelection
is still overwhelming with the
presidential election just around the
corner naay bukele is all but sure to
win but as the accusations against his
government continue to mount the
question is how much longer this
overwhelming popularity can endure
Manuel rapo Al jazer s Salvador
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer